what's happened with the gays this year
is gay activism still alive and well
i think the gays are a new white man
aren't they i think
people are quite down on the gaze at the
moment and there's all sorts of things
that you've just kind of touched on
which are quite difficult to unpack i
mean
you you were alluding to the the ideal
of color blindness which is of course
the ideal
the liberal ideal which is that as you
say the ginger hair analogy works well
because we
it doesn't mean that you don't see race
it means that you don't
uh care care you don't care you don't
you don't treat
people differently on it on on on the
basis of skin color which is actually a
beautiful
uh ideal that we should all be straight
that's how that's what we used to teach
children and
all of a sudden over the past six months
suddenly all of that needs to be
unpicked and unpacked and re
and and and revised based on this very
reactionary agenda i think that's
absolutely
uh heartbreaking and genuinely uh tragic
and yes reactionary and regressive
regressive it's taking us right back
um and that's the thing you don't need
you know we've
can anyone seriously hand on heart say
that
what has happened this year has not
inflamed racial tension and made it
worse and
and basically made our society more
racist as opposed to less racism i mean
can anyone seriously say that
with a straight face i don't believe
they can um so
that's why we do need to do something
about it in terms of gays
where are the gays andrew where are all
of the gays gone
so the the that's a different issue the
problem with the gay
issue now is that we have uh there is a
kind of
fission within the lgbtqia plus
community right so
what even using the phrase makes me
laugh i think we need to totally just
abolish it and move on because
the truth is uh let's take stonewall
stonewall which is the
sort of major charity for gay people in
the uk which has done some incredible
work over the years and has now
changed its entire philosophy about
sexuality and
it and and it believes for instance that
gay men
are it's redefining not homosexuality is
no longer same sex attraction it is same
gender attraction but of course gay men
are not attracted
to uh people who identify as men
they are attracted to people who have
the bodies of men right and that's
actually quite a fundamental distinction
a lesbian
is not going to uh be attracted to
someone with a penis simply because that
person with a penis identifies as female
and because that person says well it's a
female penis that's not because we're
dealing with people's
biological uh inclination sexual
inclinations it's quite deeply rooted
shall we say um so when
stonewall effectively adopt a homophobic
policy right and i use that word uh with
caution insofar as i don't think the
people at stonewall are homophobic but i
think their
new philosophy is underpinned by
homophobia in much the same way that i
don't think fourth wave
feminists are misogynists but their
philosophy is underpinned by
a misogynistic idea that women are weak
inherently weak and always victims and
need protection right so
it's perfectly possible uh to for this
to happen as we have seen so stonewall
now
uh are obsessed with the the trans issue
i mean their right to be
uh concerned whenever a trans person is
discriminated against
right that is something again we go back
to the liberal standard which is that
uh everyone should have equal rights
irrespective of who they are or how they
identify
the liberal perspective is that you
should be able to call yourself whatever
you want you should be able to
do whatever you want to your body uh you
should you should have though and
and of course um trans people have every
right to to be treated exactly the same
as everyone else
what they don't have the right to do is
to force other people to use the
language that they want them to use and
that's really the sticking point
um and there is this of course a
conflict of rights now between feminists
who for the most part particularly
second wave feminist and thereafter
believed in
the idea of gender being a social
construct
and of course the trans movement
particularly the militant trans
activists believe that
uh gender is uh by they have a
biological essentialist view which is
why you get this idea being born in the
wrong body
so you get this fundamental
contradiction you also have feminists
who are concerned about single sex
spaces
uh such as domestic violence refuge
centers for instance or prisons
uh which is a legitimate concern to have
uh and they they
do not believe um that biological sex is
is a fantasy
um they you know and and as blair white
as a trans writer in america has pointed
out if there's no such thing as
biological sex there's no such thing as
trans people
so all of this is going on uh so you've
got
uh lesbians and gay men uh who are being
pitted against trans activists and it's
not really fair
because the majority of trans people
don't have these views this is
this is a minority of activists who for
some reason are able to
sway stonewall's entire policy and
thinking on this and
and stonewall in fact has has completely
stopped listening
to gay people and is completely uh and
feminists and completely overall their
viewpoint
i'm not suggesting that any particular
person uh
should just be deemed to be correct in
this i think we need to have a debate
right i'm perfectly willing to be
challenged on anything that i've said
and for people to say i'm wrong i almost
certainly am wrong about a number of
things that
it's got to be the case right so having
having the discussion is important but
when you have someone just charging in
and saying
trans women are women well there's a lot
to unpack there
you know what do you mean by a woman
what does woman mean by your definition
what if i don't share your definition
of woman what if i think that um
sex is biologically ingrained and that
you are fundamentally incapable of
changing that
however you can identify and you're free
to identify however you want which is by
the way is what an awful lot of trans
people
believe right according to this new
rubric a lot of trans people are very
transphobic and that's going to be very
complicated
so what do you do gay men are not gay
men gay women
uh it's so they're lower down on the
pecking order yeah so so because of
intersectionality which effectively i
know the
original intention wasn't this but what
it has morphed into is a kind of exactly
that yeah a kind of a hierarchy of
grievance and gay people are
dropping down the charts all the time is
there any further for them to go
oh relegated to the vauxhall conference
mate you know
by the way i don't know what that means
really yeah
i just heard a man in a pub say it once
the reason i
i the reason i use that is because when
i was at school
uh it was because i'm i was never a
gender conforming kid it's about i
didn't like
the stuff that the boys liked and i
wasn't into football
and everyone was so into football i had
to pretend that i'd supported a team and
i chose
uh yeovil town so that i had something
to say
um and apparently they got relegated to
the vauxhall conference and i've always
remembered that phrase
i don't even know if the box office is
still a thing i don't think it is but
you've managed to
pull out a like couple of decade old
reference that's still in there it's
still in oh yeah well it's very
traumatic and scary you know if you're a
boy at school at your primary school and
you're secretly doing ballet in the
evenings and you're having nightmares
about them seeing you in your tights
uh and and and and you're getting
bullied at school and
and you're not considered very masculine
and traditionally masculine
uh yeah those things stick i think i
think i played cricket in
a state school in
stockton some sub-area of uh t-side
middlesbrough
whose claim to fame up until recently
was only that it had the highest teen
pregnancy rate in the uk
uh and i i was playing qriket which
which was like just the
the bourgeois arrow over the top of your
head
for uh th this guy needs a kicking
cricket cricket is basically pg
woodhouse and that kind of precisely
quick quintessential old-school
englishness and newtonian kind of yeah
that's
very very very wanky
[Music]